amsterdam central museum square has been
given over to football for the duration
of the world cup
the whole city is awash with one color
orange
the Dutch people love football and they
also love dressing up in orange colored
costumes of course the Dutch they always
really dress up for soccer why do they
do this it's always fun well it always
is orange always crazy it's just is this
all on like I see where dodge we're
proud to be touched so that's why
thousands flock to the square to watch
their national team play its last match
in the group stage with kickoff looming
it's time for the euro max world cup
test axel goes off in search of willing
contestants okay this is our scoreboard
of the euro max World Cup spirit test
right now Italy is leading okay with 21
points okay so you can score maximum of
twenty seven points you you think you
can beat this yeah I'm sure no problem
won't be problem why because we beat
spain and we bade Australia so we're
gonna beat Italy no problem we're gonna
win this time the candidates have their
own coach
a final word of instruction from him and
they're off but even with professional
coaching they only score three goals
you're the coach exactly i read on your
tie okay so they only shot three goes
what went wrong I guess we picked the
wrong strategy we should have two
children and a different player will
better with the with the legs so that
will went wrong the next round of our
world cup spirit test is our quiz okay
we want to test your knowledge on Dutch
football okay so first question how
often did the national team come in
second 33 times that's correct which
player holds the record for scoring the
most goals for the national team mr. fan
bashe that's correct okay so
congratulations three more points for
you okay our last question is which
Dutch national player holds the record
for playing the most matches I believed
it is our previous goalkeeper which is
Edwin Fonda's are that's correct
two rounds in and the Dodge fans have
scored 12 out of a possible 18 points a
pretty good result vaxcel heads off
again in search of new contestants for
the third and final round he's awarding
points for the most creative fan outfit
in Amsterdam
in the last round of our world cup
spirit test today we're giving away
points for the most creative costume
okay and you are my choice for today I
really like your costume i will give you
seven out of nine possible points that's
a good Thank You Blanca thank you sure
so so did you create this by ourselves
yes I do always every time on a party I
create special clothes because I like to
be different so we have a final result
football fans in Amsterdam have scored
19 out of a possible 27 points a pretty
good result 20,000 fans have gathered at
the museum square to watch the match and
they live up to their reputation of
being pretty relaxed until the first
goal is caught
and when the final whistle blows on
their to nil win against Chile the fans
go wild
the Dutch took only third place in the
euro max World Cup spiritus but no one
cares here anymore the people in
Amsterdam they want to win the World Cup
and everybody is convinced with this
team everything is possible and i must
confess after my day here in Amsterdam I
feel quite orange myself
you
you